on parle notamment de marielle de sarnez
lorgner sur une apparition parisienne
non non je ne peux pas vous non puisque
nous avons investi jean pierre lecoq
maire dû 6e
donc c'est un an je ne pense pas que ce
soit et pour tout vous dire moi je n'ai
aujourd'hui aucun mandat pour parler
avec le modem aucun regret venant
pilotes de fait si j'ai bien compris
françois bayroux hésitent beaucoup à
partir donc là déjà il faut que lui même
se met on paie avec supplément
d'information qui apparaît aujourd'hui
man 2 ça ne sera pas candidate
ou alors je n'avais pas eu cette
information non je dis on a investi jean
pierre lecoq sur la 11e circonscription
je pense que c'est celle là que vous
faites référence